the fundamental basis of life comes down
to this with the struggle between good
and evil the fight between light and
darkness
but in the DC universe things are not
quite so clear
heroes are sometimes complicated and
villains are always complicated when it
comes to anti-heroes no one tops the
Suicide Squad
the original Suicide Squad first showed
up in 1959 though it disappeared until
being resurrected in its modern version
in 1987 in the legend series the squad
is comprised of the world's most
dangerous criminals were on something of
a work-release program assembled by
government operative Amanda Waller they
are tasked with black ops missions in
exchange for a chance to earn their
freedoms over the world that's a good
idea
through the years the squad has had a
revolving cast of characters with a few
mainstays the crew assembled in David
Ayer's take stems from the 2011 reboot
of the comic there's Captain Boomerang
El Diablo Killer Croc enchantress
Slipknot and katana with a few of them
making their live-action debut and then
there's this guy that's Deadshot AKA
floyd lawton as he's known in the
civilian world obviously played here by
Will Smith Deadshot showed up in Gotham
as early as 1950 where he claimed to be
a crime fighter before he emerges his
Batman's enemy here's the original fancy
Deadshot who looks like a cross between
the penguin and the Joker his updated
costume usually includes a nice coppa
mask and wrist mounted guns that's
Harley Quinn one of the most popular of
all female comic characters seriously
the hell's wrong with you people for bad
guys it's what we do the former Arkham
psychiatrist who went crazy after
falling in love with the Joker didn't
actually make her debut in a comic but
in Batman the Animated Series artist
Paul Dini got the inspiration for Quinn
while watching the soap opera days of
our lives where his friend Arleen Sorkin
was playing a clown in a dream sequence
David Ayer maintained Queens iconography
but updated it giving Margot Robbie a
playful but deviant look and what would
Harley Quinn be without
the Joker Ayers Joker played by Jared
Leto is tatted out and styled after drug
lords the a or saw on Instagram
controversial maybe but apparently the
tattoos tell part of Joker's backstory I
can't wait to show you my toys
indeed Suicide Squad might be our first
chance to really explore some of our
favorite characters stories the time has
come for the bad guys to shine